le cancer de la prostate troisième cause
de décès par cancer au pays est souvent
difficile à diagnostiquer avec précision
entre cancer évolution lente qui n'a pas
nécessairement besoin d'être traités et
un cancer agressif comme le carcinome un
pra canalaire qu'il faut soigner
rapidement les avis peuvent différer
d'un pathologiste à un autre mon travail
c'est d'identifier cette variante
agressé villa du cancer la prostate en
utilisant finalement mes yeux au
microscope parce qu'on a très peu
d'outils qui nous permettent de
confirmer
qu'est ce qu'on est en train de regarder
c'est bel et bien mais l'équipe la
docteure trudel travail et mettre au
point une technique pour résoudre ce
problème
elle combine deux outils pointe les
spectroscopie laser et l'intelligence
artificielle le laser permet d'analyser
finement les molécules des échantillons
de suprises vie chez un patient et
l'intelligence artificielle permet de
classer automatiquement les résultats
selon le type de cancer et le risque
qu'il représente ce qu'on veut essayer
de faire en fait c'est de diminuer cette
variabilité là pour que quand le
diagnostic il est posé l'urologue le
radio oncologues qui va traiter le
patient va avoir une meilleure
connaissance en faire du cancer de son
patient et cette connaissance lors être
fiable
les tests réalisés jusqu'ici sur près de
500 biopsie démontrent que leur
technique est parvenu à détecter neuf
fois sur dix la présence ou l'absence
d'un carcinome qu'on parle de médecine
personnalisée en fait depuis longtemps
et c'est des découvertes comme ça qu'ils
vont nous aider à raffiner encore plus
la certitude qu'on peut observer de
façon sécuritaire où on doit traiter de
façon immédiate un cancer combien de
diagnostiquer l'équipe chine devrait
encore réaliser quelques milliers d'
analyse de tissus avant de confirmer que
leur méthode est efficace mais la
docteure trudel est confiante
on a des bonnes chances en fait une fois
que les données vont être validée avec
plusieurs instruments que ce soit
implémenté en clinique 20% des décès par
cancer de la prostate sont causées par
un carcinome intra canalaire
is normal grande un réseau canada
montréal